>> Tucker: BILL DE BLASIO MAYOR
OF NEW YORK GOT BORED WAITING
FOR HIS DEALER TO ARRIVED AND
TRIED TO CANCEL THE TRIBUTE TO
911 BECAUSE CORONAVIRUS.
PEOPLE NOTICED AND WERE
OUTRAGED.
CANCELLING ITS 911 MEMORIAL.
HE REVERSED COURT.
BILL DE BLASIO IS STILL A BIG
FAN OF SHUTTING DOWN THINGS THAT
PEOPLE ENJOY PARTICULARLY
TRADITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
AROUND.
HE HATES THE PAST.
TRYING AGAIN.
THE MACY’S THANKSGIVING DAY
PARADE WON’T REALLY BE A PARADE.
BILL DE BLASIO DOESN’T REALIZE
PEOPLE MIGHT NOT LIKE THIS.
WATCH HIM SELL THIS NEW FORMAT
FOR THE THANKSGIVING PARADE.
>> IT WON’T BE THE SAME PARADE
WE ARE USED TO.
IT WILL BE A DIFFERENT EVENT.
REINVENTNG THE EVENT FOR THIS
MOMENT IN HISTORY.
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO FEEL THE
SPIRIT AND THE JOY OF THAT DAY
ON TELEVISION, ONLINE.
NOT A LIVE PARADE BUT SOMETHING
THAT WILL REALLY GIVE US THAT
WARMTH AND GREAT FEELING WE HAVE
ON THANKSGIVING DAY.
>> Tucker: REINVENTING THIS
EVENT FOR THIS MOMENT IN
HISTORY.
NEW YORK IS REINVENTING ITS
CRIME STATISTICS FOR THIS MOMENT
IN HISTORY.
HUNDREDS OF COOPERATIONS IN NEW
YORK ARE PLEADING WITH THE MAYOR
TO CRACKDOWN ON CRIME AND SAVE
THE CITY AND IMPROVE QUALITY OF
LIFE.
CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
THERE AND PAY FOR THIS NONSENSE.
IS HE RESPONDING?
SETH BARREN LIVES IN NEW YORK.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
PEOPLE HAVE CONFRONTED.
STEAK  -- STAKE HOLDERS
CONFRONTED BILL DE BLASIO.
WHAT IS HIS RESPONSE?
>> THEY ARE BEGGING HIM TO TAKE
LEADERSHIP AND SEIZE THE MOMENT
TO FIX THE CITY.
HE KIND OF HAS THESE FECKLESS
RESPONSES.
THE THANKSGIVING DAY PARADE IS
A NATIONAL EVENT.
IF WE HAD IT, IT WOULD SIGNAL
NEW YORK CITY WANTS TOURIST.
WE ARE OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
THIS IS WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS.
BILL DE BLASIO ANYTHING THAT IS
CHEER
CHEERFUL AND WHOLESOME, HE WANTS
TO SQUASH BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE
THAT WILL OBEY THE LAW.
IN WASHINGTON SQUARE PARK EVERY
WEEKEND REFUSE FASCISM HAS
A PROTEST PARTY WITH A DJ AND
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE DRINKING AND
DANCING.
BILL DE BLASIO IS PERMITTING IT.
>> Tucker: YES, HAS DE BLASIO
EVER BUILT ANYTHING OR DOES HE
ONLY DESTROY IT?
HE IS SYMBOLIC OF THE LEFT.
GOOD AT WRECKING THINGS BUT BAD
AT BUILDING THINGS.
HAS HE BUILT ANYTHING?
>> THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION.
HE HAD A PLAN TO EXTEND THE
SHORELINE OF MANHATTAN INTO THE
EAST RIVER.
I DON’T THINK THAT WILL HAPPEN.
NO.
I CAN’T SAY HE BUILT VERY MUCH.
HE POURED PUBLIC MONEY INTO
REHABBING APARTMENTS.
BUT I CAN’T SAY HE IS BIG ON
BUILDING THINGS.
HE IS MORE ON RE-DISTRIBUTION.
THAT’S WHAT HE DOES.
TAKES WHAT OTHER PEOPLE HAVE AND
GIVING IT TO OTHERS.
>> Tucker: THE OPPOSITE OF
CHARITY.
FORCING OTHER PEOPLE TO GIVE.